Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers amis
vous comprendrez que nos premiers mots
soit
pour nos amis turcs qui ont été
endeuillés par un abominable
attentat qui fait honte à l'idée que
nous nous faisons tous de la
civilisation et qui montre les
responsabilités qui vont peser sur nos
épaules devant ces barbares qui à
travers le monde s'iment la terre hor
reur la violence ni tout ce que en quoi
nous croyons
l'humanité la
civilisation l'humanisme et bien sûr nos
pensées vont aux victimes et à ce pays
qui est un grand pays qui vient d'être
frappé une nouvelle
fois je voudrais puisque c'est la
dernière convention avant le Conseil
national de samedi remercier vraiment
une nouvelle fois
ERC vert notre secrétaire général qui
fait un travail
[Applaudissements]
remarquable vraiment c'est une chance de
l'avoir à ses
côtés c'est sincère tu le sais et puis
je voudrais avoir un mot tout
particulier pour notre vice-présidente
Isabelle le calenc qui
[Applaudissements]
avec discrétion avec solidité avec
loyauté
euh ça fait une une une belle équipe et
je suis vraiment
heureux d'être à la tête de cette équipe
euh naturellement je remercie Daniel
parce que sinon il peut me couper les
[Applaudissements]
vivres vraiment
vous me permettraz également d'avoir
une une pensée très très amicale pour
françois Barouin le président des ma de
[Applaudissements]
France je suis content François
contraenson et à mon avis c'est que le
début et
puis merci à Virginie du
buuminaire merci à Claude Greff merci à
Marie Josie Merman merci à Guillaume
Larrivet à tous ceux qui ont participé à
cette table
ronde vous êtes de bonne humeur
là bon mes chers amis nous sommes face à
une crise de
confiance sans
précédent c'est pas la peine de nous
payer de mot et nous sommes nous
aussi au cœur de cette crise de
confiance
il y a pas une institution il y a pas
une
catégorie et qui est à l'abri de cette
crise de confiance François barroin a
raison il y a un attachement à la
commune il y a un attachement au maire
mais bon après 4 années de François
Hollande plus personne ne croit
personne l'exemple venant de haut cher
George c'est toute la
pyramide de la confiance nécessaire dans
les institutions d'un pays
qui se trouve aujourd'hui gravement mis
en cause j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à cette
crise de confiance et je crois
profondément que la première chose que
nous devons avoir à l'esprit pour
rétablir un minimum de
confiance il faut le refus obstiné du
mensonge et le courage de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle et de l'honnêteté des
sentiments je ne dis pas de la vérité
parce que je sais trop avec l'expérience
qui est la mienne que la vérité
peut-être multiple il y a la vérité du
moment il y a la vérité des personnes il
y a la vérité des territoires mais
l'honnêteté intellectuelle le refus
obstiné du mensonge qui a ravagé
l'esprit public qui croire quand le
président de la République a menti si
souvent et de façon et honté voilà la
question qui nous est posée et
naturellement elle nous
impacte comment pourrait-il chercher
d'en être
autement nous sommes dans dans dans ce
pays et dans ce moment il nous faut donc
repenser notre façon de vivre notre
modèle démocratique alors je sais bien
c'est pas facile qui une lassitude
François Barou en a parlé à juste titre
pour les changements institution
le bricolage institutionnel et en même
temps on peut pas faire comme s'il se
passait rien comme s'il y avait rien à
dire comme s'il y avait rien à faire
alors dans le projet des républicains et
je sais bien que l'ambiance est sensible
sur ce mot il y a d'abord la question du
référendum j'ai été un peu étonné de
certains commentaires que j'ai
entendu le référendum deviendr
deviendrait donc
illégitime à partir du moment où la
réponse du peuple ne correspond pas à ce
que les élites imaginait que devrait
être la réponse intelligente je
m'inscris en faux complet avec cette
analyse
complet je vrais rappeler quand même que
pour nombre d'entre nous nous sommes les
héritiers d'une tradition politique et
la tradition
Gauliste je ne dis pas que le référendum
doit servir à régler tous les problèmes
je ne dis pas et l'exemple
anglais très intéressant de ce point de
vue que le référendum doit être engagé
n'importe comment à n'importe quel
moment sans d'autrees projet que de
pousser les gens à refuser parce qu'il
n'y a pas un projet en face mais
l'idée que nous les républicains nous
souhaitons associer davantage le peuple
AUC
majeure CHPP que nous prendrons c'est
une idée très importante je souhaite
qu'elle soit retenue et je voudrais
prendre un exemple de mon point de vue
je veux le dire je crois que ce fut une
erreur de supprimer le service national
sans demander au français de se
prononcer par le d'un
référendum on peut avoir et franis et Mo
en a parlé on aura l'occasion de dire
des choses sur le sujet moment
venu
mais c'est une question simple parce que
tout le monde est censé avoir fait son
service militaire en tout cas
moi c'était il y a quelques années faut
bien le
reconnaître mais chacun pouvait se
prononcer par oui ou par
non et les
décideurs n'avait qu'à se
conformer à ce qui exprimait le peuple
moi je peux pas considérer que le
référendum
anglais 74 % de
participation près de 18 millions de
gens qui votent non so un détail qu'on
peut traiter d'un revers de la main et
dire mon Dieu ils se sont trompés
j'aurais préféré que la Grande-Bretagne
reste dans l'Europe mais enfin il faut
respecter le choix qu'ils ont fait et je
conseillerai d'ailleurs aux dirigeants
français de ne pas donner trop de leçons
puisque je me rappelle moi qu'en 2005 il
y a eu un
référendum sur l'Europe qui a donné 55 %
de
nom donc le recours au
référendum la possibilité de pour le
peuple de trancher il me semble que
c'est la meilleure façon de
résister à la tyrannie des minorités
auqu nous nous assistons aujourd'hui
c'est donneré la possibilité à la
majorité de faire entendre sa voix ce
sera au cœur de la pratique
institutionnelle de l'alternance que
nous mettrons en euuvre alors j'ajoute
sur le référendum que dans mon esprit le
référendum sur notreame des Landes c'est
l'inverse de ce qu'il fallait
faire parce que
entre pardon David Cameron qui fait un
référendum sans proposer un projet et
NotreDame d' lande ou après des années
d'hésitations 160 décisions de justice
on finit par vouloir
s'abriter derrière un un référendum
parce qu'on arrive vraiment pas à
prendre une décision ce qui est
lamentable en démocratie et ce qui
monque la perte complète d'autorité de
pouvoir en
place et bien qu'au moins maintenant je
le dis au gouvernement de notre
République
tirer sans délai les conséquences de la
consultation de dimanche et évacuer sans
tarder des gens qui occupent une
parcelle du territoire la République
française et qui n'ont rien n y faire
qu'attendez-vous pour
agir où on
est
alors je souhaite également que nous
posions la
question de l'inflation
insensée auquel nous avons assisté des
normes car finalement la la
République
liberté est devenu un lieu où comme tout
est interdit on ne sait même plus ce qui
est
permis et il est bien loin le temps où
l'on disait nul n'est censé ignorer la
loi qui
ici
s'aviserait même de prononcer cette
phrase sans prendre le risque Jean-Paul
de recevoir des
colibet puisque y compris lorsque vous
voulez démêler un problème il y a plus
un seul avocat qui peut être votre
avocat il faut des spécialistes de tout
parce qu'on ne comprend plus rien la
seule chose qui est la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui personne n'a la force de
faire et chacun a la force d'empêcher de
faire c'est la
paralysie par un afflux de normes de
réglementation tuérique notre
compétitivité et qui donne de la
France l'idée d'un territoire où
l'innovation l'initiative le risque ne
sont plus les bienvenus donc nous
souhaitons
adopter ce que les Anglais appellent
sunset clause c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y ait
plus une seule
norme qui ne soit bornée dans le
temps par une date limite un peu comme
les produits alimentaires il y a une
date de péremption ça tombe car le
problème avec les normes c'est pas tant
leur accumulation c'est qu'on se bat
comme des déchaînés
entre les pour et les contre et puis une
fois que c'est adopté ça tombe dans un
trou noir
définitif plus personne
n'évalue et les couches de norme
viennent se rajouter aux couches de
norme créant une cathédrale juridique
dans laquelle personne ne peut se
retrouver c'est très simple les
prochaines normes s'il y en a 5 ans au
bout de 5 ans bilan d'évaluation et s'il
y a pas ce bilan la norme tombe la règle
ça sera que sans volonté de faire
perdurer la norme elle tombera je
souhaite également que l'on réfléchisse
à l'idée de 3 jours pour notre Parlement
qui serait réservé à l'examen du stock
de
norme et je vous garantis qu'il aura de
quoi faire et que les 3 jour par
an seront
largement
occupés je voudrais d'ailleurs que nous
déclarions cher François pour les zones
rurales pour les zones de montagne et
pour
l'outrmer un moratoire sur la durée du
quinquena à Cherny pour toute nouvelles
normes parce que ces territoires n'en
peuvent plus ils ont été victimes de
surcroix d'un effet silo de ministères
qui prennent des normes qui s'abattent
sur les mêmes territoires sans qu'à
aucun moment il y ait une coordination
interministérielle pour dire où on est
où on en est et comment les choses
peuvent se résoudre j'ajoute un dernier
point je souhaite que l'on redonne du
pouvoir au préfet tu en avais parlé
François et je pense que sur tous norme
chaque préfet devrait avoir la
possibilité de décider d'une
adaptabilité de 20 % de la norme en
fonction du territoire dont il a la
responsabilité on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
exactement les mêmes règles pour les
crèches selon qu'on soit dans un
territoire rural Cherni ou au cœur de
Paris chère
Brigitte nous allons crever
littéralement de cette
uniformité alors que la France est
composée de la diversité de ces
territoires à ce moment de mon propos je
voudrais poser une question très
sensible qui est l'affaire des
parlementaires de leur nombre et des
mandats qu'ils peuvent exercer
j'été 20 ans
parlementaire et je veux dire parce que
je le pense que des assemblées
plétoriques deviennent des assemblées
inaudibles je voudrais qu'on se réveille
tous nous avons pas moins de 1000
parlementaires en France 1000 si vous
ajoutez
députés sénateur parlementaire européen
ça fait un parlementaire pour 70000
habitants en France
l'Allemagne 1
pour3000 j'ose à peine dire pour les
États-Unis 1 pour
566000 voilà les propositions que nous
voudrions faire la première c'est que je
souhaite que le nombre de parlementaires
ne soit plus fonction des habitants mais
des inscrits à partir du moment où les
étrangers ne votent pas en France on ne
doit pas tenir compte du nombre ch dans
une circonscription pour décider d'une
circonscription ou pas ce sont les
inscrits les inscrit je mets de côté les
élections européennes et les élections
municipales puisque comme vous le savez
une règle particulière mais parfois je
vois certains départements notamment en
région parisienne qui ont un nombre de
parlementaires
immense qui ne correspond nullement au
nombre d'inscrits et qui correspond à la
population deuxème remarque nous
souhaitons proposer une réduction de 30
% du nombre des parlementaires français
afin de les porter d'ici 2022 ça
donnerait 400
députés 202 sénateurs au lieu des 577
députés actuels et des 348 sénateurs
actuels étant entendu que le redécoupage
serait pour 2022 ce qui donnerait le
temps de repenser les choses calmement
et é entendu également qu'il n'est pas
question de laisser un département sans
un parlementaire ça va de soif en je il
y a des départements qui ont maintenant
un seul
parlementaire et pas question
naturellement de leur
supprimer je souhaite également qu'on
prenne une décision très
forte je dis parce que c'est le fond ma
conviction que des parlementaires qui
n'auraient pas de mandat local qui
feraient la loi du lundi au dimanche
sans un enracinement dans leur
territoire ce serait une erreur
gravissime nous avons besoin de
parlementaires qui sont
enracinés dans leur
territoire et c'est à VOUS français de
décider si vous voulez ça soit stop
ou encore et donc je considère que
chacun doit pouvoir alors il peut y
avoir des gens qui disent moi je
souhaite le mondat unique je respecte
j'ai pas de de problème du tout
là-dessus mais je suis très attaché à
l'idée que vos législateurs est un
enracidement territorial qui est utile
pour le territoire qui a besoin d'un
leader et qui est très utile pour
l'assemblée cher Claude ou le Sénat qui
a besoin que remonte un un oracinement
territorial qui est naturellement perdu
si on coupe cette possibilité j'ajoute
pour le dire au français que avec le
mandat unique on augmente de 30 à 40 %
la quantité le
nombre de membres de la classe politique
alors que je pense qu'il faut le réduire
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec les
cantons ù maintenant dans le même canton
il y a deux conseillers
cantonal alors ça permet pour la parité
c'est très bien excusez-moi le problème
de la France c'est qu'il a une classe
politique trop nombreuse et que nous
voulons une classe politique moins
nombreuse et de meilleure
qualité alors comment va-t-on faire et
bien c'est assez simple je propose que
le jour du deuxèe Tour des législative
suivant la
présidentielle le jour même il y a un
référendum portant sur ces questions de
réduction du nombre de
parlementaires de demandat et pas un
seul de plus et de suppression d'un
certain nombre
d'institutions pour montrer aux Français
que l'alternance elle commencera 6 mois
après
elle commencera pas 6 mois après mais
tout de suite nous voulons une
démocratie plus vivante ça
des institutions à
supprimer nous avons fait avec é le
conte c'est très simple depuis
1978 il n'y a pas moins de 40 autorités
dites indépendantes je me demande
d'ailleurs indépendante de
qui indépendante de
quoi à partir du moment où elles sont
nomm moi je connais l'indépendance de
responsables politiqu qui sont élus et
qui peuvent être battus je connais
l'indépendance d'un électeur qui choisit
une majorité ou une autre je connais pas
l'indépendance d'un expert qui est nommé
par celui qui l'a nommé et qui n'a
ensuite de compte à rendre à personne
surtout pas à celui qui l'a
nommé à moins qu'on m'explique que sa
légitimité vient à la longueur de ses
études nous c'est pas ce qu'on veut donc
nous
proposerons une loi qui fixe le nombre
de ces autorités indépendantes et nous
proposerons y compris dans ce référendum
la division par
de du nombre des autorités indépendantes
et dans le même temps je souhaite et je
le dis à mes amis que ça soit le
politique qui reprenne sa responsabilité
et sa légitimité car c'est trop
facile si on est élu c'est pour prendre
des décisions alors je sais
monsieur Holland après le brexit a dit
qu'il était triste on était inqu pour
lui mais c'est parce qu'on attendre un
président de la République donc que les
choses soient claires pour
moi j'estime que la commission des
affaires culturelles de l'Assemblée du
Sénat est plus légitime y compris par un
vote à la majorité qualifié pour élire
les dirigeants de l'audiovisuelle publi
une autorité
indépendante j'estime que la commission
des affaires économiques de la emblé du
Sénat est plus légitime pour décider ou
non d'un 4è réseau plutôt qu'une
autorité prétendument réseau
téléphonique plutôt qu'une autorité
prétendument indépendante naturellement
il y a après un travail François de de
gestion d'animation et je comprends
parfaitement que tout ceci peut rentrer
en ligne de compte mais nous voulons
moins de parlementaires qui prennent
plus de de décision qui assume davantage
de responsabilités et je ne vois pas
pourquoi on considère que c'est un
progrès démocratique de retirer des
pouvoirs au Parlement pour les donner à
des autorités qui n'ont pas vocation à
être élu qui n'ont jamais été élu et qui
ne rend compte de leurs actions à
personne voilà ce qu'on pense et il me
semble que c'est alors je sais bien
alors après des sujets sensibles le la
réforme que j'ai fait la nomination de
la à la des dirigeant d'autor de médias
public je je peux tout à fait
reconnaître que c'était pas forcément la
meilleure idée je suis tout à fait prêt
à revenir dessus mais il me semble qu'à
partir du moment où il y a une majorité
qui sort des urnes qu'elle assume ses
responsabilité en en faisant des choix
suffisamment dignes et avec une certaine
hauteur de vue et la majorité qualifié
obligera à ses choix plutôt que
d'autorité indépendante qui ne me
semble-t-il ne vont pas dans le sens de
la revitalisation de la démocratie
française alors dedans la un problème
particulier qui le Conseil économique et
social je dois faire la synthèse bien
sûr je je m'interroge d'autant plus que
je trouve que la réforme du Conseil
économique et social que j'ai conduite
n'a pas été un succès vous savez moi je
suis pas quelqu'un qui pratique le
mensonge ou la langue de bois quand je
crois que chose je me bats pour le faire
passer puis quand je me trompe je dis
oui sans doute je me suis trompé bon
j'ai vu le rapport de la cour des compte
très sévère sur le Conseil économique et
social et
franchement on est en droit de se
demander à quoi
sert-il en même temps je ne veux pas
faire de procès d'intention déplacé à la
nouvelle équipe peut-être fera mieux que
la précédente il n'aura pas beaucoup de
mal de de de de de ce point de vue pu
donc notre idée c'est de dire que sauf
éléments nouveaux et on est prê
convaincu le Conseil économique et
social a plutôt vocation à disparaître
sauf si on nous montre que c'est utile
mais il faudra nous le
montrer quant au conseil dans les
régions économique et sociales notre
idée c'est de dire à chaque région de
décider si vous le gardez ou si vous le
supprimez mais en tout
cas le message que nous envoyons c'est
plus de
référendum moins d'autorité indépendante
pour plus de responsabilité politique
moins de parlementairire pour
revitaliser la force du Parlement et de
mandat pour s'assurer que les
parlementaires et vos législateurs et
bien les pieds ancrés dans leur terroir
et pas simplement la tête à faire des
schémas idéologiques et des lois dont
vous avez plus casser voilà le projet
politique qui est le
NRE
je je me bat là-dessus je je vous
demanderai de voter là-dessus dans le
cadre de la consultation je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut je je je je le pense
profondément et je crois que ces idées
sont de nature mais c'est pas les seules
à changer les choses alors autre sujet
extrêmement sensible et B il faut qu'on
en
parle combien de fois ai-je rencontré
des Français me disant ah bon vous avez
dit idées c'est bien c'est pas bien mais
de toute manière l'administration vous
les laissera pas
appliqué
sous-entendu soit idéologiquement ils
seront contre le gouvernement et donc
vous ferez pas ce que vous nous avez
dit soit simplement il y a un effet de
résistance puisque les ministres ça
passe les directeurs ça
reste enfin vous avez entendu comme moi
ce ce sujet bon il se pose d'une façon
qui est absolument incontournable
aujourd'hui on a la pire des solution on
a des ministres qui en général n'ont pas
confiance en leur directeur et qui
doupent leur directeur avec des cabinets
ministériels plétoriques et oui parce
que le ministre travaille pas avec son
directeur puisqu'il a pas confiance dans
le directeur donc il travaille avec un
conseiller dont il croit qu'il peut lui
faire confiance ignorant que le
conseiller qui a choisi a fait les mêmes
études et à le même âge que le directeur
qui n'a pas
choisi c'est du vécu c'est du vécu c'est
du vécu et le ministre pense celui qui
court les routes contre celui qui se dit
de droite qui a le même âge et les mêmes
diplômes et celui qui se dit de gauche
qu' le même âge et le même diplôme il y
a pas de de passerelle de discussion tu
sais ça va pas très bien pour vous en ce
moment mais rassure-toi demain c'est r
mieux en tout cas passe-moi la rub on va
le Saer
et ge le truc voil c'est ça ENF allez
caricature je suis bien je suis bien
d'accord mais enfin il y a un petit peu
de vrai voilà ce que nous on on a
beaucoup travaillé n'est-ce pas é
n'estce pas Isabelle sur le sujet et
voilà ce qu'on
propose il nous semble qu'il est
important que le Parlement puisse sur la
proposition du gouvernement fixer une
liste de direction de directeur dont il
considère que c'est les principaux
directeurs pour mettre en
œuvre sa politique est-ce que c'est les
20 est-ce que c'est les 30 est-ce que
c'est les 40 premiers directeurs peu
importe mais il est vrai qu'avoir un
directeur du budget qui croit pas dans
la politique que met en vre le ministre
du Budget ou avoir ch un directeur de la
de
de des des des des grâces et des des
voilà c'est
excuse-moi des affaires répétez pas he
que que j'ai j'ai eu un TR de mémoire
c'est bon des affaires criminelles les
des grâces qui partage pas la position
du garde des saau ou avoir un directeur
du Trésor qui conteste violemment la
politique
économique ça de sens pour personne donc
je voudrais que le Parlement réfléchiss
sur cette trentaine ou cette quarantaine
de
directeurs que chacun de ces directeurs
reçoiv du gouvernement une feuille de
route correspondant à la politique de la
majorité qui sort des urnes et que sans
hypocr
au moment où la nouvelle majorité arrive
elle nomme à ses postes des femmes et
des hommes qui croient dans la politique
que démocratiquement ils mettront en
re et tu vois bien Françis le
schéma je je le je le lis à ce que je
disais au début le refus absolu du
mensonge le refus absolu de l'hypocrisie
refus absolu des faux
semblants voilà ce que nous voulons
faire voilà comment nous allons le faire
pas de
combine pas tout d'un coup c'est exemple
pris au hasard la désignation d'un
procureur dont on apprend après qu'il
avait son service militaire avec
quelqu'un hein ou non non c'est pas du
tout lié hein c'est bien sûr ou ou telle
présidence dont on apprend après qu'elle
est très proche non la démocratie c'est
le refus de
l'hypocrisie et il me semble qu'avec ça
on vous garantit que le gouvernement se
dotte des moyens de mettre en œuvre la
politique pour laquelle il a été élu et
pas une autre un mot pour terminer mais
François a déjà tout dit sur l'affaire
des collectivités territoriales parce
que c'est une affaire extrêmement
sensible et très importante parce que là
aussi on est pris dans un effet
cisoérique bien sûr il y a les élus qui
nous disent on n'en peut plus et
notamment les mères qui sont exposés
comme jamais donnez-nous de la stabilité
n'est-ce pas Jean-Paul on veut de la
stabilité laissez-nous tranquillees on
comprend plus rien à votre
mécano j'entends ce message mais de
l'autre côté alin il y a tous ceux qui
nous disent vous pouvez pas nous laisser
dans cette situation-là il y a la loi n
il y a la réforme des rythmes scolaires
il y a tout ceci et l'alternance vous
allez pas considérer comme un alpha et
un Oméga les lois votées par la gauche
avant vous donc comment on arbitre cela
et bien nous allons essayer de faire les
choses de la façon
suivante nous ferons une loi de liberté
locale pour le prochain
quinquena cette loi définira clairement
les compétences régionales et
départementales dans mon mon esprit
c'est clair compétence générale état et
commune compétenence spécialisée
département et région pas de
compétenence général pour les
départements et pour les régions juste
pour les communes et pour
les
deuxièmement je ne crois pas au mariage
forcé et obligatoire et automatique
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire à
partir du moment il y a un bassin de
population on doit se retrouver dans des
intercommunalités qui ne veulent rien
dire avec des gens qui ne veulent pas
vivre ensemble qui ne veulent pas
travailler ensemble ça ne peut se faire
que sur la base de la volonté et non pas
sur des critères administratifs qui
tombent sur un territoire et qui en
vérité le brise étant entendu pour ma
part je voudrais rappeler je suis très
opposé à l'élection suffrage universel
des intercommunalités parce que je pense
que le suffrage universel c'est pour les
communes et que si vous élisez les
intercommunalités au suffrage univ vous
brisez la logique communale monsieur le
Président de l'Association des
ma j'ajoute la possibilité
d'expérimenter on n'est pas obligé
d'être organisé de la même façon sur
tout les parcelles du du
territoire nous déciderons d'une
nouvelle carte cantonale parce que celle
de l'actuelle découpage de 2013 est un
scandale démocratique et nous
proposerons la réintroduction du
conseiller
territorial qui permet de rapprocher
départements et régions sans lancer la
France dans un débat dont nous ne
sortirons pas entre les régionalistes et
les départementalistes
cherti avec le Conseil Territorial on
aura en élisant le conseil territorial à
la fois le Conseil départemental et le
conseil régional ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes je l'entends bien de
taille des assemblées
mais ça on le réglera dans le cadre du
découpage cantonnal avec des cantons
plus importants et quant aux régions
dont nous avons
hérité notre idée c'est d'être
pragmatique d'interroger région par
région celles qui voudront rester
ensemble et celles qui voudront se
séparer je ne suis pas impressionné
parce que c'est une loi socialiste mais
je vous demande pas non plus parce que
c'est une loi socialiste de la mettre à
Baras il faudrait pragmatique et les
solutions seront région par région on
prendra un peu de temps pour voir cela
il y a pas besoin de créer les
conditions d'un affrontement entre des
gens qui veulent rester mariés et des
gens qui veulent se séparer
enfin nous allons reprendre l'idée d'une
loi de financement d'autant plus que
c'est celle de de
François il faut que les élus sachent au
début du quinquena quel va être le
contrat financier entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales les
collectivités territoriales ne peuvent
pas être la variable
d'ajustement des dépenses décidées par
l'État et qui renvoie les
dérembboursements à la sécurité sociale
pour pas prendre de responsabilité et
les augmentations d'impôts aux
collectivités territoriales pour leur
envoyer popularité chaque année une loi
de finan parfait on en décide et
souhaite que pour la durée du quinena on
est un contrat où chacun d'entre vous
sache exactement où il en est et
qu'est-ce qu'il pourra faire alors il y
avait bien d'autres sujets qu'on aurait
pu évoquer bien
sûr je sais qu'il a des partisans d'une
nouvelle
République le Premier ministre et ceci
nous l'avons pas voulu pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que la 5e
République fait chaque jour un peu plus
la preuve de sa solidité et de sa
capacité d'adaptation parce que pour
résister à 4 années de François Hollande
c'est vraiment que nos institutions
[Applaudissements]
son j'ajoute que je ne suis pas persuadé
que le débat sur la crise de confiance
sera
résolu ou que le fossé se trouvera
réduit uniquement parce qu'on décidera
qu'il faut plus de Premier ministre ou
un premier ministes ou le nombre de
ministres je n'y crois pas je crois
beaucoup plus à ce que nous avons dit
sur la loi de finance territoriale sur
les direction d'administration sur les
autorités indépendantes sur la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires je pense que
on a essayer de vous proposer les bases
d'un mouvement institutionnel qui est
beaucoup plus pragmatique
qu'intellectuel qui est beaucoup plus
pratique que théorique et il me semble
que c'est notre rôle à nous les
républicains de faire ainsi voilà mes
chers amis en vous remerciant de votre
attention et en vous donnant rendez-vous
samedi pour le Conseil national
final